there are intense negotiations underway
about the timetable to withdraw all the
UN peacekeepers in Mali less than two
weeks ago the foreign minister of Mali
surprised the UN by demanding the
mission manusma closed down as soon as
possible the French delegation has been
working to draw up a resolution it
currently says it has the objective that
all peacekeepers should be out before
the 31st of December
the government of Mali backed by Russia
wants them to leave faster than that
possibly within three months the un's
spokesperson has been stressing that to
do such a drawdown in a place where
there's still a great deal of violence
and instability takes time any effort to
move thousands of peacekeepers including
all their equipment all their facilities
all their supporting staff
takes uh takes a period of time and and
so you can see from our past withdrawals
from places that we need a a reasonable
timetable and and of course it'll become
clearer through our dialogue with the
members of the security Council what
that timetable will be this map in un
headquarters shows where the United
Nations is operating in Conflict zones
the circles are the peacekeeping
missions minusma in Mali is one of the
largest it's also the most expensive and
the most dangerous
174 peacekeepers have been killed and
over 700 injured in the last decade
things on the ground remain bad and
after the UN leaves the government of
Mali now intends to further rely on the
mercenaries from the Wagner company
there are about 900 of them but of
course there are now questions about the
company's operations following the
rebellion in Russia last week James Bays
Al Jazeera of the United Nations